ora
perché da
come sono adesso
voglio il mio letto sono costrette ad
urbino quali la volte da bagno
[Musica]
anita
capitale
ciao come stai oggi bene devo dire che
questa ma subito abbastanza bene strano
che devo dormire nella vasca e non del
letto ma è l'unica soluzione adesso con
questa coda mi sento come un pesce fuor
d'acqua
ma prima o poi riuscirò a tornare
normale vero
spero proprio di sì che riusciremo a
risolvere questo
problemino
problemino non posso camminare devo per
forza stare nell'acqua e ti sembra un
problemino è un problema
sentito
sembra che provenisse dall'altra stanza
vuole controllare sbrigativo e un posto
camminare pari o che no che ha fatto
questa
è un messaggio forse di chi mi ha
trasformato in sirena che cosa dice ciao
vita la prova di oggi sarà trovare tutti
i propri tano il mio elemento nel mio
elemento ci sono anche delle onde ho
capito
credo il mio elemento dovrebbe essere
l'acqua visto che stiamo parlando di
sirene quindi devo trovare i bobbit
nell'acqua questo montare in piscina e
trovarli questa è una delle prove sempre
facile come prova credo o forse
diventeranno sempre più difficili beh
comunque devi portarmi in piscina e di
portarli in braccio per minor costo
camminare un giochino da per cena va
bene ti prendo io adesso il braccio e ti
porto subito in piscina così risolviamo
subito questa maledizione tutte le date
sono in piscina da sirena e si sono
ipocrita nascosti nella piscina riuscita
a vederlo se guardate bene nel fondo
della piscina si riescono a vedere
riuscirò a recuperarli tutti sono
tantissimi quanti saranno secondo voi
provate indovinare qual è il numero di
pop hit nella piscina e vediamo alla
fine del video che si è avvicinato di
più al numero è giusto ok e iniziano a
prendere il bomber
riuscirò a ruotare da pirelli
e bellissimo avere la coda
in effetti sì proprio la bella sirena
beh però stai attenta quando vai a
prendere i popoli e va bene proprio
stare attenta io mi butto ok io ti seguo
da qui
come l'acqua e frutti
prova a prendere il primo può cristo ma
vediamo che cos'è
devo capire bene come nuotare con quel
qualcosa non è facile essere sirene
sembra facile ma non lo è ho imparato
non tanto dai che ci sono tanti pop hit
league e ti aspettano a prenderne uno
[Musica]
il mio primo figlio
durissima
[Musica]
credo che abbiamo recuperato tipo qui
penso dobbiamo contarli adesso
sto allenando la coda ancora non riesco
a nuotare bene contro stacco dalla
sirena ma avranno trovato tutti i propri
tavoli vediamo eccole qua
c'è qualcosa col salto guardo
abbiamo dimenticato quello sì lo prendo
subito
vai
[Musica]
o raccontiamo tutti i pochi
quando no
giunto ora mi devo riprendere dai almeno
qui è meno profondo vi prendo subito fi
[Musica]
cioè adatto alla piscina dai ce ne sono
ancora un paio di
è stancante per una sirena è
brava nei presi due ai sirena poi
non mi piace per portarmi fortuna
due brani porta e te ne è rimasto solo
uno da prendere quello lì 0 2 ha solo
due
agli ultimi due
sono fatta eccoli qua gli ultimi due
papi tra un'ora montiamo quanti ne
abbiamo presi vediamo chi ha indovinato
ok vediamo quanti sono vaio 2 3
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 erano 13 pop hit avete
indovinato
devo dire che questo sale già stata
stancante con questa o da gigante da
essi non deve essere facile notare con
quella coda troviamo il mio pop hit
preferito fra questi
il pesce rosa che si era nascosto
il mio rimane esempio il coccodrillo
sempre in ambito acquatico e là sotto
guarda
è il vostro preferito qual è ma ora che
abbiamo terminato questa charlene
zuccoli altre challenger ci aspetteranno
lasciate un mi piace per scoprirlo e ora
vi lasciamo con quattro case viene su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
ciao